uh hello my name is mario aquino i'm one
of the organizers of the strange loop
conference and in this episode i'm going
to be talking to
joel holdbrooks who i know is falcon
jewel and i uh worked together we've
worked together in the past
um and we're going to be talking about
his
closure library called meander which is
something that was featured in a talk
given by jimmy miller
in 2019 at strange loop um if you have
any questions about the conference
uh this year you can read more about it
at
the strangeloop.com
so with that out of the way uh let's get
started
falcon how's it going all right
how are you uh very well so
um i what i wanted to talk to you about
um
was about meander so um
i mentioned that jimmy uh gave the
talk on it uh back in 2019
um and you know in in this conversation
we can talk about
um you know where meander has
uh gone uh since uh he gave the talk
uh in the talk jimmy talks a little bit
about um
the sort of uh plans uh
for sort of short-term and long-term
plans for meander
i'd also like to talk about um your
inspiration
for meander and what it is for anybody
who may be watching this
who didn't get a chance to see jimmy's
talk which is on
youtube for anybody viewing um
this discussion if you want to watch
jimmy's talk on meander
it's available on our youtube channel uh
so
um falcon can you tell me what was
what was your inspiration for writing or
at least yeah
writing meander in the first place oh uh
gosh um lots of things uh
honestly um just day-to-day programming
um was uh was a big part of that
um just sort of observing um
relationships between um you know things
that
people were doing as well as
um and connecting that to pattern
matching um
i would you know observe um you know
during pairing sessions
people would write code a certain way
and i was like oh that's that looks a
lot like a pattern match
and then um also noticing that um
you know after uh they had done
something
uh to get data in a certain uh it'll
pull pull certain information out of the
data
uh then they would want to you know put
it back together in a different way
and um sort of that uh
i started paying a lot of attention to
the asymmetry
um in in that uh so we do things like we
do structure
uh we we pull data apart in one way and
then we
put it back together another way um or
an
entirely different way and to me that
was um
kind of kind of strange after a while um
because
you know in mathematics um you you you
don't really work
this way um you know the symbols uh
you know move from what one side of an
equation to the other side of the
equation
and there really isn't a difference
between the the two sides
um so uh this kind of bugged me for a
long time and i
and i couldn't i didn't know what
was going on there and then eventually i
encountered the space
uh called rewriting
um which is which is all about this it's
all about
uh taking uh some uh
pile of symbols and uh turning it into
some other pile of symbols right
um and they're usually systems of these
that describe how to
um one particular shape of symbols and
turn them into another one
um booster like this there's lots of it
in logic
um so uh i i wanted to bring
uh this um sort of
way of working with symbols uh to
closure
so that that was uh that was the idea
and inspiration there's more to it but
that's
that's sort of the longer short of it
that's one of the sort of classical
problems
for programs would you agree that um
programs take
data that looks like you know one thing
and it needs to make it look like a
different thing following
whatever sorts of rules and as common as
that is
it seems like meander is trying to
scratch that particular itch
um in you know as a
convenient and expressive way as
possible
yeah that's that's the goal um it's it's
it it certainly sounds easier than it
actually is in practice right uh because
um you know it turns out there are many
types of uh i i would i guess i would
describe it as behaviors uh that people
um
you know uh express when they're when
they're coding
um and it you pattern matching
um works really well up to a certain
point
using like the sort of classical
approach to pattern matching
um that you encounter virtually
everywhere but at some point
um it's not robust enough to um
to do things that people are often
interested in doing
such as aggregation for example
so one of the challenges has been to
[Music]
figure out a way to build into
this system the primitives that
allow for things um like aggregation
um so if i could stop you there just for
a second um
i i want for anybody who's either uh not
familiar with meander or not familiar
with pattern matching
um i i guess what i'd like to do is have
you
um just describe a little bit what the
idea of pattern matching
is absolutely yeah go ahead yeah
definitely
um so pattern matching um
so there's many different kinds of
pattern matching um i think one of the
ones of
one kind that most people are familiar
with is is um
are regular expressions so um you know
those
uh describe uh the shape uh of a string
and um you know it'll given given some
string
uh it'll tell you whether or not uh the
string
that uh you you have matches the
the pattern and um there's extensions to
regex that probably everyone's familiar
with
that would allow grouping and capturing
and and this kind of thing
um but uh the the general idea
is that um you have um
a uh a structure
which looks uh very much like
um another structure a concrete
structure
uh so this could be a list uh it could
be a vector it could be a
set or a map which i'll talk about in a
minute because those are very different
from the other two
um it could be numbers uh what have you
right so
the idea is that using that description
um
or that that structure you have these um
placeholders or these variables and the
idea is that the variables
uh will bind to um items uh
or elements of the structure uh that
you're matching
and then make those accessible to you
for for programming so
a really example example might be let's
say um
i'm trying to um well the most simplest
one is like
let's say that i have a variable x or x
can be it can be anything so
if i'm going to match uh that variable x
uh it could match with anything in the
universe let's just say one
and then x would be bound to one and
then i have a um
usually what's called the right-hand
side of a match which is where i can use
that
binding x you know so i i might add x or
put x in a box or something like that um
but then you can grow this out to
something like well let's say i want to
describe a list maybe of three elements
so i might say well i have a list of x y
and z
and then you hand me one two and three
i can line those up x is one y is two
and
c of three and then i can go on and use
those
um i think many people encounter a type
of pattern matching called destructoring
um in the field so it's it's in pretty
much every mainstream language that i
can think of now
um but certainly ones that um
people use a lot like javascript you've
got
destructuring there so it's very similar
so you have an object destructor or
rady structure so it's looking for
something that
um looks like a an object or looks like
an array
that pulls those things apart and makes
those um those bindings accessible
so the the the uh i'd say
something that would be closer to like a
a more
um you know mathematical definition of
it would be
that you're given a pattern and an
object that
you it's a function that you know if the
uh object matches the pattern then you
get a set of of bindings out of it
which is just a mapping from a variable
to
a value now
for for most of the way people use
pattern matching that they do what i
just described it so you've got a
pattern match and then you've got a a
right-hand side which is usually your
ordinary code
um but in rewriting um it's
it's uh yeah it's just another pattern
on the right side except the difference
is instead of
that pattern being for matching it's
it's it's going to take those bindings
and then build a new structure out of it
so
in the the xyz example i gave you let's
say i match a list x y z
maybe on the uh right hand side
i have a pattern that just says x and z
so this pattern says if i have a list x
y z
well then i want you to turn that into
the list xz
right so that's the general idea here so
you're not coding
uh on the right side you're just
applying the bindings you got from the
left side to the right side to produce
more data right on
so the idea of meander is to give you
ways of doing pattern matched
rewriting where you express patterns on
the left and right side
or you can express patterns on the right
side and
so besides patterns uh what else can you
like what can you incorporate into those
patterns on the right side let's say
well i mean it it it depends on
on what you allow what your language
allows
um so meander sits on top of
closure so um it's going to try and
um make something some things like
function application
uh you know available to you so let's
suppose
you know i go back to that list where i
matched x y and z
um then maybe i want to uh
turn all of those into strings so
there's a way
to say on the right hand side hey um you
know
when you when you're something you would
say substituting when you're
substituting x over here
um i want you to call this function on
that value so
maybe you call stirrer on it or
something like that um
but if we were maybe uh using this
language in isolation
you know in its own space maybe it
wouldn't have that feature because
it's not it doesn't have a host language
that it's interacting with
so it just depends uh on on um
what uh the language allows for um
but that would be uh arguably the
the big one right because you you wanna
be able to talk to
the host language in particular for
things that
the pattern matching language can't
express uh yet
right and i say yeah because there are
lots of things that are
currently available on the on the on the
main branch of the project that you
can't do
that i have plans uh to make work on
um on on the new on the new version that
i've been working on
so you mentioned the host language and i
want to ask
uh so you mentioned being able to use um
meander enclosure uh does meander uh
also work in closure script it does yep
so in an enclosure script uh it it
actually works on
javascript objects which is a lot of fun
um because it has a very uh
liberal take on what it means to pattern
match uh
uh an object um so
uh there you can in anything that
basically has uh properties on it you
can
you can pattern match with so it's fun
to pull it into node
and uh uh pattern match on process and
you know that that pattern matching
could work like oh you know uh on
um pulling out system information or or
or whatever you want and then uh pattern
matching on it i haven't done as much in
javascript as i'd like though
um but you can do it and you can also
match on arrays as well
you can further extend the language too
uh there mander has
facilities for extending it so if you
wanted to um have it do more
uh interesting things that it doesn't do
out of the box then
you can make it to other things so um i
want to kind of go back to something
that you were
just saying uh moments ago about what is
possible to do on let's say one branch
of uh the repository for the project
that you have
and kind of relate that to um i guess
future future plans near or sort of just
future
plans for me and or the things that you
want to try to focus on
feature wise or or anything else right
so
um like i mentioned earlier the the
kind of one of the big drivers uh for me
in this project
is um i want uh i want
um i want a symmetry
um it is something that i would like to
have more of um i really like this idea
of symmetry i also like the idea of
duality
and i i want to have those ideas
um be at hand uh
in in this language um before you go
much further can you say a little bit
about what you mean by symmetry and
duality
just for context yeah so uh for for
uh for symmetry what i just mean is that
something that you can express on the
left-hand side
uh of a rewrite rule i believe you
should also be able to express
on the right-hand side and currently um
there
are constructs that are exist on the
left-hand side
that don't exist in the right-hand side
and the main reason
that that's the case is that i didn't um
i didn't have a semantic
or an idea of how to make that work i
didn't have a i didn't have a notion of
so pattern mention has this this notion
of failure right which is
that if i give it the wrong uh type of
data it fails to match the pattern
okay so that's pretty that's a pretty
easy
um uh thing to to do
um when i was doing the right hand side
i didn't know
uh what the semantic for failure should
be or i didn't have a semantic for
failure um
but since uh um you know 2019 i've
figured
figured it out right um and
so that's basically what i that's that
was basically preventing me
from having that that property of you
can whatever you can draw on the left
you can draw on the right
um and there's a there's a semantic uh
that that makes sense for both
you know um part part of the thing that
was holding me back there is
uh there is a constraint on
uh logic variables so a logic variable
for anyone that doesn't know
is a is a variable which um represents
the
the uh the same or equivalent value
wherever it appears
so if i have a going back to that list
again if i say if i have a list of x
x it's going to be looking for a list of
like one one
two two x has to be the same value
when you're when you have a disjunction
or an or
uh in a pattern match you're saying i'm
going to match either this thing
or that thing now in pretty much
every system that exists you have to
have the same logic variables
in both sides you know or they have to
have been bound elsewhere so
i can't say or xy because
i don't i don't know what to do with
that if i maybe i get
x maybe i get y um but i you know
uh i don't know how to express the lack
of
x or the lack of y for the right side
um so uh
what i i decided was is that on the
right hand side
if you just if you refer to something
that's not bound so if that x isn't
bound or that y isn't bound
it'll cause the the substitution to fail
you know
so that's the idea that way you don't
have this limitation of not being able
to
um to uh you know
you have to be required to write things
a certain way
and i think there's utility in that
being able to
have those kinds of semantics and part
of this
is responding to the fact that people um
constantly bring this up as a pain point
right this this this constraint and i i
don't want to appeal to
pragmatism too much here but i think
it's really worth listening to
to devs on this kind of thing you know
so um at the end of the day
you want to take these cool ideas and
give them to people um
but you also don't want to
limit yourself to uh whatever
uh you know rigid sort of
framework uh you know might might exist
in academia because
maybe that's not as useful to people in
practice you know
um and that you can come up with
something to make it useful so that's um
yeah so now there's a way to have that
symmetry you can use or on the left you
can use or on the right
but if you have things that aren't bound
then it's going to fail
you know so you could say something like
oh i'm going to match x and then i'm
going to rewrite it to y
that's never going to to work because y
will never get bound
or never be bound and maybe that sounds
like nonsense um
but it's it got it semantics so
uh right anyway
um all right so
so um beyond um
trying to add uh symmetry or trying to
get closer to
a symmetry between the left and right
side
uh is there anything you can say about
um
performance uh in the library i remember
that was something
oh yeah that jimmy talked about a little
bit in the talk in 2019
yeah so we we have um
we we have made leaps and bounds in in
terms of performance
um we
people will bring things to us so
there's a by the way there's a there's a
channel a clojurian slack called meander
um we always welcome people to come
there and complain
tell us what's not working out for them
tell us when things are slow
when maybe they think they should be
fast and fortunately we have had many
people uh do this they'll give us an
example of something that's
hey this is 10 times slower than closure
and we'll go take a look at that and hey
maybe we can make it
go faster because we might see something
oh well this pattern um
we can reduce it to this uh or or
rewrite it to that
and you know so um we're getting fewer
and fewer of those kinds of um
requests now because i think we've
closed the gap on most of the big ones
and uh you know in many cases we can get
very very close to handwritten code
sometimes
faster depending on the pattern and
what's going on um
and that largely depends on two things
first of all you know when people hand
write code
they're going to hand write code in a
way that's convenient for them to write
so maybe they'll do things that aren't
actually very performant
and sometimes you know maybe the problem
that someone's trying to solve
they they're not familiar with it and
they write it a certain way and
has certain performance characteristics
that make it slower or something like
this
um what we're aiming for is we're trying
to be
as fast as you know probably the code
that you would want
would say hey that's a pretty good
solution that you know that's what we
what we want to aim for
um and so we we've uh we've definitely
made a lot of
um improvements there um
the the next version of the library um
i think will continue to have uh more
performance uh improvements and and
probably um
i i think actually even some memory
improvements too i haven't spent a lot
of time
um looking at that but because of
uh the what i was just was talking about
symmetry right so we have the same
things on on both sides for um
your rewriting um we can exploit
a lot of the the relationship between
the left and right hand side
and we can close the gap on you know
generating code we do a lot of dead code
elimination um
there's a lot of inference that we can
do um because
the both sides are speaking the same
language
right on well um
[Music]
joel i want to thank you for uh sitting
down with me today
um i look forward to watching the
progress
of meander do you have an idea for
um timeline when you would like to
uh or i should say what are the things
that you want to
try to tackle before doing uh next major
release
so um yeah so i
i would i definitely want to get the
next uh iteration of the project out
this year
um last year with kobit my kids were
home uh
we had homeschooling you know uh my open
source work
i couldn't keep up with it um but now my
kids are you know going back to school
and and
um i'm able to get more a job stuff done
like was supposed to so i have more time
for open source so i i
i plan on having it uh released sometime
this year
um i just want to quickly say that the
challenge in getting it from where it is
now
oh sorry from where it was to where it
is now is that i wanted to
address all of the problems that people
have come up can come to me with
um people want to have uh you know they
want to be able to have an interpreter
so they can hand quoted
patterns in and or construct patterns
and you know
uh no macros i still want macros
um people want uh explanations they want
to know why something
didn't do uh what they think it's
supposed to do i want that too
because i have to debug these things
occasionally um
and i also wanted to set a unified
framework for for doing all of this
and that took time to figure out how to
build um
now that i've got uh that figured out
and i'm able to
to build on top of this framework to
deliver all of those things it's
mostly a large large amount of it is
testing everything um you know and
um you know solving uh problems that uh
i didn't anticipate
you know i dealt with some problems of
divergence and and
you know things uh just kind of spinning
uh on some of these rewrites and i
you know that's just debugging stuff
that you have to deal with
um but fortunately i've closed a lot of
those gaps
and i'm much closer now than i was
before
so before the end of the year i don't
want to promise any specific
dates or anything but i definitely
believe before the end of the year
awesome well um thank you once again
uh so i have been talking to joel
holbrooks
uh who is known as no prompt on lots of
places
uh i know him as falcon and uh thank you
for watching uh
for folks who are considering coming to
strange loop this year we hope to see
you
we also hope to put uh ticket
availability
online uh sometime soonish
uh please watch the strange loop
twitter account to learn more or the
website
thank you
you